that's the breaking news just in a
report by her majesty's inspector of
constabulary has found that the
metropolitan police acted
appropriately at the vigil held in
memory of sarah everard on clapham
common you may remember pictures around
some controversy of
police moving in on women
who attended the vigil well scott's home
affairs correspondent mark white joins
us now from west london mark tell us
more
yes i mean an eagerly awaited report of
course because there was a lot of
concern expressed by
senior politicians including the home
secretary the prime minister
leader of the opposition the liberal
democrat leader of course calling for
the metropolitan police commissioner
cressida dick to resign so this
report by her majesty's inspector of
constabulary
uh an insight into whether those police
officers
acted proportionately and according to
that top line
from this report it does indeed say that
the metropolitan police acted
appropriately now it goes on
to say adam that hmicr
found that the metropolitan police was
justified
in adopting the view that the risks of
transmitting covet 19 at the vigil
were too great to ignore when planning
for a policing event now some key
pointers in
their findings they say police officers
at the vigil
did their best to peacefully disperse
the crowd
police officers remained calm and
professional
when subjected to abuse and it says
police officers
did not act inappropriately or in a
heavy-handed manner
clearly from the metropolitan police
commissioner crested the dick's
viewpoint she will be very pleased and
i'm sure relieved to see the conclusion
here from her majesty's inspector of
constabulary
there is some criticism for the met
though in terms of the senior
management team it says that
inspectors found there was insufficient
communication between police commanders
about the changing events on the ground
so in terms of the
uh the command of what was going on
those instructions that were filtering
down to the officers
a better lack of communication there but
the officers on the ground the way that
they dealt with it
uh the report found that they acted uh
proportionately
uh in and they acted and not in a
heavy-handed manner
uh in dealing with uh what they were
facing which according to this report
was increased levels
uh of abuse uh tom windsor who is
her majesty's inspector of constabulary
has put out a statement
uh he said the commission uh
commissioners and i received
uh from the home secretary and the mayor
was a
request to inspect this he says public
confidence in the police is critical
it is therefore important that there has
been an independent objective
evidence-based inspection to provide
public
uh reassurance which we provide today
he said our civilian police model is
precious officers
are our fellow citizens invested by the
community
to keep the community safe they rely
uh upon and are entitled to receive
public support when they act lawfully he
said
sensitively and proportionately in this
case
in the face of severe provocation and
very difficult circumstances
they did just that um so as i say
as far as the met police commissioner is
concerned she will be
i'm sure delighted to read the outcome
of the inspector constabulary's findings
here although
as i say there is some criticism of the
way in which commanders
relayed instructions between them and
down to those officers on the ground but
as you see the key point from this
these officers did not act
inappropriately they were not
heavy-handed
uh that in the circumstances as they
faced
increasing hostility and abuse from the
crowd they acted uh with restraint
i'm still reading this report so there's
a good few uh other pages to go
uh i'm told that there might be a line
or two criticism for
the london mayor in there so i'll just
have a quick read of that adam and i'll
get back to you
with exactly what that says